hinse le washington post the guardian
der spiegel hugo
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mardi 11 janvier
manuel macron qui a présenté cet après
midi ses voeux à la presse l'occasion
pour le chef de l'état d' évoquer
notamment la lutte contre l'effet
quiniou surtout en cette période de
pandémie ou les complotistes selon lui
se saisissent de cette crise pour lancer
des rumeurs le président qui appelle
aussi les journalistes citoyens et les
médias étrangers à faire preuve de plus
de rigueur et de vigilance une alerte
lancée au moment où la commission
brauner sur la désinformation et le
complotisme a remis son rapport
controversé décrit talent dans quelques
instants avec nos invités
emmanuel macron qui a réagi un peu plus
tôt dans la journée à la grève des
enseignants prévue jeudi la moitié des
écoles pourraient être même fermé une
mobilisation nationale contre le
protocole sanitaire mise en place dans
les établissements scolaires et ce
malgré un allègement décidées par le
gouvernement fini les tests pcr à j + 0
pour tous les élèves d'une classe soins
qui a été détectée désormais un simple
autotests suffira
dans notre deuxième partie d'émission
nous arrêterons sur la situation au
kazakhstan ce pays d'asie centrale
secoué la semaine dernière par des
violences sans précédent pour le
président kazakh son prédécesseur serait
à l'origine de ces émeutes sanglantes
aujourd'hui les choses semblent
s'apaiser les troupes étrangères menées
par la russie venu en secours d'almaty
doivent même quitter le territoire dès
jeudi de façon progressive et s'il peut
être d'un retour à la normale un nouveau
cabinet ministériel a été nommé on fera
une analyse avec alexandre del vals
j - 89 avant la présidentielle et si
jean luc mélenchon marine le pen ou
encore eric zemmour ne pouvait
finalement pas s'y présenter ces trois
candidats en tout cas s'inquiète faute
de parrainages suffisants à ce jour ils
demandent l'anonymat des élus accordant
leurs signatures pour le gouvernement
hors de question de changer des règles
et vous qu'en pensez-vous le système des
parrainages est-il obsolète on attend
vos réactions pour alimenter le débat de
21h
[Musique]
emmanuel macron a donc a présenté ses
voeux à la presse cet après midi le
président a renoué avec l'exercice deux
ans reporter lucas léger devant l'elysée
bonsoir le cas lors de cette conférence
de presse le chef de l'état qui a
notamment évoqué la lutte contre l'effet
toulouse alors qu'il a reçu aujourd'hui
le rapport de la commission brauner sur
ce sujet
absolument et ce à un long discours
auquel s'est livré le chef de l'état en
présence du bureau de l'association de
la presse présidentielle et d'autres
représentants de la profession il a
démarré par son discours son discours
sur la question d'olivier dubois otages
au mali il les a assurés qu'il assuré
que les services de l'état étaient
mobilisés pour permettre la libération
de cet otage il a aussi rappelé que
l'état avait été aux côtés de la presse
financièrement pendant la crise du coc
vide 19 483 millions d'euros donnés en
2020 sur 20 ans supplémentaires puis il
a abordé le coeur de son discours la
lutte contre l'effet que nous à des
informations sur internet sur les
grandes plateformes sur les réseaux
sociaux il a pointé du doigt les
algorithmes opaque selon lui et il a
accusé des puissances étrangères de
vouloir exploiter ces failles je vous
propose d'écouter ce qu'il a dit
les plateformes numériques celles et
ceux qu'on appelle les influenceurs les
citoyens aussi qui parfois prennent une
place
considérable dans le débat public par le
biais justement de ces nouvelles
plateformes de ces nouveaux réseaux qui
en achetant d'ailleurs de l'axé qui en
le développant par telle ou telle
pratique doivent avoir un cadre de
responsabilité qui est à construire
ils doivent aussi en être de même pour
les médias étrangers autorisés à
diffuser sur le sol français et je le
dis ici avec beaucoup de gravité
nous sommes aujourd'hui nous démocratie
en quelque sorte
parfois naïf qu'en utilisant le cadre
d'information qui est le nôtre et ceux
de notre loi nous laissons des acteurs
de propagande financé par des régimes
autoritaires étrangers qui ne sont
absolument pas qui ne répondent en aucun
cas un régime de responsabilité ou de
déontologie journalistique informé
participer aux débats comme des
journalistes et donc nous avons une
responsabilité collective à préserver un
espace public où circule une information
libre plurielle et diverse où chaque
citoyen peut être confronté à une idée
et à son opposé pour cela
il faut que le cadre de responsabilité
soit clarifiée et renforcée compte tenu
de ces nouveaux acteurs
alors vous l'avez dit la commission
bronner contre la désinformation sur les
grandes plateformes numériques a rendu
son rapport aujourd'hui le président il
a fait référence plusieurs fois au cours
de ses voeux à la presse il a déclaré
que ce travail était excellent et qu'il
posait les bases d'un futur débat public
ce qui laisse penser que si emmanuel
macron est réélu il y aura de nouvelles
discussions peut-être une loi sur ces
questions mais la commission broehner
vous l'avez dit allez controversée
certains de ses détracteurs et biens
accusent cette commission d'être une
nouvelle initiative de l'état pour
prendre le contrôle pour reprendre le
contrôle de l'information est tout
simplement pour eux c'est une entorse à
la liberté d'expression merci lequel
elle gère en direct devant l'elysée des
voeux des manuels micron à la presse en
pleine campagne à trois mois de la
présidentielle alors qu'il n'a toujours
pas officialisé sa candidature c'est
l'heure de notre décryptage avec nos
invités
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler jonas à
d'adorateurs de valérie pécresse
candidate de l air à la présidentielle
2022 bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés en direct par skype france
quatre boeufs délégué départemental du
modem dans le nord bonsoir france 4
boeuf et merci également d'être avec
nous en direct on évoquera en tout à
l'heure l'un des autres grands titres de
l'actualité en cette grève de jeudi à
l'école qui s'annonce massive pour
exprimer le ras-le-bol concernant le
protocole sanitaire mais d'abord on
s'arrête sur ses voeux des manuels
maquereau à la presse un haut début de
ce rendez-vous d'ailleurs le président
de l'association de la presse 1
présidentielle lui a lancé cette petite
phrase un peu taquine dans une
démocratie moderne on tient des
conférences de presse c'est vrai que au
début de son mandat emmanuel macron ne
voulait pas vraiment obtenir ce genre de
rendez-vous il était en campagne il
s'agissait de se rabibocher avec les
journalistes frantz pas trop boeuf
ou je ne perçois pas à cela qu sous cet
angle j'ai plutôt l'impression que la
situation actuelle est trop difficile
compliqué tendu mouvante un cadre
institutionnel comme il l'a dit
d'ailleurs peut s'avérer utile parce que
un peu de solennité un peu de sérieux
dans une époque où tout le monde dit un
peu n'importe quoi sur n'importe quel
support ne peut pas être être critique
et donc je pense que je pense qu'il a
raison de s'institutionnaliser parce que
cela on oublie la fonction
j'ai écouté avec attention ce que dit
l'intervenant précédent est ce qu a dit
le président macron depuis des mois
c'est la personne qui fait des tic toc
envie en tee shirt pendant l'été c'est
la personne qui dit qu'ils emmerdent les
personnes qui sont non vaccinés donc
pour le cadre institutionnel on
repassera je pense simplement que
monsieur mâcon et la raison d'un point
de vue stratégique en tout cas ils
essayent de jouir à la fois de la
position de président et de la position
de candidat mais ce
ce double sa double casquette elle va
pas tenir très longtemps d'ailleurs le
président des républicains christian
jacob a demandé des comptes dès
aujourd'hui sur les déplacements du chef
de l'état parce qu'on voit bien qu'il
est en campagne il fait des chèques à
tout le monde il s'adresse à tout le
monde comme s'il était en campagne et
pourtant rien n'est comptabilisé donc un
moment je comprends ce que vous dites
sur le cadre institutionnel mais s'il ya
bien une personne qui a cassé les codes
de la communication présidentielle on
l'a vu lors de la fête de la musique à
l'elysée je le rappelle avec des images
qui nous marquent encore on l'a vu
lorsqu'il était à saint martin avec ces
délinquants qui faisaient des doigts
d'honneur je pense que si on a bien un
qui n'étaient pas dans le cadre
classique c'était bien emmanuel macron
la france 4 bat vous comprenez tout de
même que ça
agace un petit peu les amis républicains
ils ont peut-être plus de mal à afficher
leur candidature d'ailleurs comme tous
les autres candidats alors qu emmanuel
macron lui se paye peut-être une une
tribune de luxe en ce moment alors qu'il
n'est pas encore déclaré officiellement
candidat alors que tout le monde sait
qu'il va se représenter il n'y a pas une
concurrence déloyale
oh vous savez la vie politique c'est un
éternel recommencement
moi je me suis engagé au modem contre
casse toi pauvre con et nicolas sarkozy
au congrès contre l'emmerdait les
citoyens alors eh bien
et à chacun de porter sa croix à tour de
rôle voilà un bon alors nous centristes
c'est vrai que préférons une folie des
reprises c'est incontestable nous sommes
minoritaires prier ensemble les énervés
de gauche et a levé les énerver droite
c'est vrai
alors le président de la république peut
être soupçonnée de faire campagne à la
fin antar comme avant lui françois
hollande bien qu'il ait renoncé à se
représenter comme avant lui françois
mitterrand comme avant lui nicolas
sarkozy comme tous les autres poêles à
bron à écouter c'est tout c'est comme
cela on peut elle pas d'accord on peut
le critiquer mais le prochain président
fera la même chose enfin si si comme
nous le souhaitons emmanuel macron est
réélu ta question ne se posera pas dans
cinq ans et nous aurons des candidats
tout neuf à présenter aux suffrages des
français
alors en cours de ses voeux en tout cas
en revenons à ses voeux à la presse un
emmanuel macron c'était le sujet a parlé
de l'évolution du métier de journaliste
et de ses dangers
il a d'ailleurs lancé cet avertissement
et côté
le métier de journaliste est bouleversée
partout y compris dans de grandes
démocraties par une conjonction aussi
inédite de phénomène
le modèle économique de votre profession
d'abord est battue en brèche par
l'avènement de grandes plateformes de
l'internet et de la société du tout
gratuit vous l'avez parfaitement dit je
reviendrai sur plusieurs
points que vous avez mentionné la
révolution numérique ensuite change
profondément la production même de
l'information
là où elle est et le monopole de
personnes formées pour cela aujourd'hui
chacun smartphone à la main ou clavier
au bout des doigts peut s'improviser et
je pèse mes mots journalistes comme le
dit un de vos confrères la presse de
plus en plus c'est donc devenu je le
cite entre guillemets un combat de rue y
en a ça date en ce sens le président a
distribué un petit peu les bons points
et les mauvais points certains médias
d'ailleurs comme france 4 qui la pompe à
une salle de classe géante pendant le le
premier confinement
il faut vivre avec son temps et faire
avec et ne pas forcément dénigrer où il
est dans son rôle et il a finalement
raison avec ce type de discours non là
dessus vous voyez comme quoi on n'est
pas des opposants énervé comme le disait
notre intervenant précédent moi je
partage totalement le constat des
maillets macron aujourd'hui tout le
monde s'improvise journalistes des gens
s'improvisent aussi influenceurs et
selon mots de michel denisot une
influence que les influençable et
effectivement il ya de plus en plus de
personnes qui croient des théories qui
sont ridicules véhiculées par des gens
simplement au motif qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'abonnés et donc c'est drôle là pour le
coup d'un présent la république que je
trouve que c'est bien qu'il y ait eu une
réflexion autour de ça de s'intéresser à
ces nouveaux modèles parce que sinon
effectivement ce sera des théories qui
seront pernicieuse qui auront d'ailleurs
un impact sur la démocratie parce que
c'est effectivement en voyant des
fausses rumeurs envoyant des fausses
informations que les gens vont se
décider de plus en plus d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que au sein de l'équipe de
campagne de valérie pécresse
on s'occupe d'une série qui s'appelle la
cellule riposte on voit des fausses
informations qui sont véhiculées par
tous les candidats et c'est notre
responsabilité en tant à la fois que
responsable politique mais aussi de
journalistes de faire en sorte que le
choix des citoyens soit un choix éclairé
macron des grands
mais ont réédité ce qu'il demande c'est
de fait rentrer l'ensemble des acteurs
de la formation dans le cadre législatif
de la loi de 1881 il n'y a pas de droits
sans devoirs c'est à dire que tout le
monde peut s'exprimer librement mais à
condition de respecter le cadre de 180
talent et pas du tout une atteinte à la
liberté d'expression c'est simplement
responsabiliser vous êtes journaliste
vous c'est votre métier vous êtes
responsable et y est normal que toutes
celles et tous ceux qui portent une
information soit responsable de la même
manière en fait c'est tout simple et ne
puisse pas rater de quoi sous l'anonymat
et donc effectivement cette campagne pas
vous avez toutes les campagnes sont
difficiles bien sûr qu'elle sera qu'elle
sera brutal comme toutes les autres
campagnes mais ce qui est important
c'est travailler dans la durée c'est à
dire que vous savez la campagne dans six
mois elle est terminée et donc si ce qui
est important c'est que nous puissions
avoir un cadre institutionnel durable
parce qu'on sait bien que les chaînes de
télévision traditionnelles vont aller en
déclinant et il faut faire rentrer dans
ce cadre de responsabilité l'ensemble
des intervenants de l'information
publique comme privée c'est tout simple
et c'est tout à fait
je serais ravi france 80 que vous nous
qualifiez de journalistes parce que on
va essayer de prendre un humour le
président a parlé de la naïveté un jeu
site de la france de laisser on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure un lait je cite
les puissances étrangères
c'est un petit peu visé faire leur
propagande comme des journalistes qui
sous-entendrait qu'on n'est pas vraiment
je précise au président de la république
que nous avons une carte de presse et
qu'on
n'applique notre métier qu'on exerce
notre métier le plus honnêtement
possible je tenais à le préciser et ça
serait d'ailleurs on journalistes entre
eux de faire le tri entre les médias
fiable
nous ne sommes pas naïfs il ne s'agit
pas que de qualité de l'information il
s'agit aussi de savoir nous protéger là
aussi contre des ingérences de
puissances étrangères dont les
intentions sont très clairs et qu'ils
profitent de la pleine liberté que le
relais sont alors même souvent que ces
deux mêmes puissances vous empêche de
diffuser ou d'exercer votre profession
sur leur territoire
commence à se développer à cet égard des
processus d'autorégulation de
certification qui sont portées par vous
même par vous représentants pour
travailler avec les rédactions avec les
journalistes pour aider les citoyens les
acteurs privés les plateformes les
annonceurs des acteurs publics
les régulateurs aussi et pour identifier
les média fiable
fiable parce que le processus de
production de l'information répond à des
critères déontologiques de base
journal ce qu'il soit contrôle qui
identifie les média fiable
alors toute profession à un organisme de
régulation donc ça on peut pas contester
le fait que ce soit nécessaire mais
c'est assez curieux de voir ça de la
part d'un président qui enregistrer une
émission quelques jours à l'avance
contrôler et sur la première chaîne de
télé en france ces terres qui s'est payé
un spot publicitaire en réalité un et ça
me rappel vous savez dans ce film oss
117 dans lequel le français vient donner
des leçons aux étrangers en disant vous
êtes une dictature et puis après on lui
dit mais vous êtes vous même avec un
militaire à la tête de l'état et une
télévision qui est contrôlée qui était
le rtf de l'époque ait dit oui mais
c'est la france du général de gaulle bas
c'est un peu ça la france d' emmanuel
macron c'est qu'effectivement parfois
emmanuel macron il utilisait à plein les
bleus vielles de son pouvoir
présidentiel pour contrôler et pour
avoir un message qui est très contrôlée
à son avantage et d'un autre côté ils
regrettent des ingérences de puissance
étrangère je pense que chaque
profession doit voir sa régulation et
même pour ceux que ce soit pour votre
chaîne ou pour les chaînes étrangères
voilà ça
existe donc je pense que ça c'est
légitime et personne ne peut y échapper
et d'ailleurs même s'il ya des critiques
qui sont formulées à l'encontre de
chaînes qui sont d'origine étrangère il
faut les entendre mais
venant de la bouche de quelqu'un qui a
un vrai contrôle de son image politique
et qui jouit de tous les leviers en tant
que président de la république c'est
assez cocasse france quattro boeuf
nous exposait jonas haddad
les mobilités en tout cas de vous
exprimer sur sur notre chaîne mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya deux poids deux mesures
emmanuel macron et peur peut-être de la
contradiction selon vous mais vous savez
ça me fait penser à cette phrase de
françois mitterrand l'auteur de ce
magnifique pamphlet le coup d'état
permanent qui disait la vème république
était dangereuse avant moi elle le sera
de nouveau après mois
rappelons-nous mon contradicteur et est
l'héritier d'alain peyrefitte de son
mouvement politique lorsqu alain
peyrefitte était ministre de
l'information le contenu du journal de
20h se décider dans son bureau et donc
nous sommes aujourd'hui à là encore dans
cette époque est celle d'une forme
d'autoritarisme pauliste une forme de
mainmise sur l'information
vous faites rien j'espère que c'est bien
enregistrer ce que vous êtes en train de
dire pour aux pauvres vise à dire que
ces derniers enregistrent est ce que
vous êtes en train de lire pour preuve
vis-à-vis des manuels macron c'est un
aveu incroyable vous comparez ces
interventions à celle de l'eau et rtf ce
que je veux lui simplement et qu'il faut
démocratiser notre système que ce départ
arrivée secouette mais que en tous les
cas si on peut constater une chose en
revanche c'est qu'il n'y a il y a la
possibilité pour le président de la
république de s'exprimer effectivement
prioritairement sur les grands médias
mais cela n'empêche pas un certain
nombre de médias qui parfois
appartiennent eux à des groupes
financiers de mener des politiques de
communication très agressive envers le
pouvoir politique il m'arrive de
regarder ses news il paraît que
d'écouter europe 1 on ne peut pas dire
que ma famille politique qu'il soit
particulier en morgue et retraités eh
ben vous voyez monsieur c'est peut-être
la différence entre vous et moi moi je
préfère que des chaînes financées par
des capitaux privés et leur propre
opinion que ce soit l'impôt des français
le vôtre est le mien qui finance des
opinions qui ne sont absolument pas si
vous voulez neutre quand je vois ce qui
se passe sur les chaînes du service
public parfois avec une orientation et
une ligne politique qui est extrêmement
clair soit en faveur du gouvernement
soit on éclaire sur une sur une île qui
est plutôt de gauche je préfère des gens
qui se paye potentiellement une ligne
politique que des gens qui font payer sa
part les contribuables oui ça c'est
certain c'est une divergence entre nous
une réponse ma tête
y'a pas la vérité l'ajout fait une vraie
réponse de centristes n'y a pas de
méthode parfaite oui les journées une
services publics sont majoritairement à
gauche monsieur zemmour voulu mettre de
l'ordre dans leurs commandes est il fait
rival et épurée je vous rappelle qu'il
ya d'autres chaînes ou si l'on n'ose se
moquer de monsieur pro aux licenciés
lendemain alors si vous voulez le
problème c'est que quand vous êtes dans
une société privée vous devez respecter
la ligne officielle non vous êtes guéret
quand vous êtes dans une société
publique l'impôt des français sert
majoritairement effectivement à financer
une ligne qui est assez marquée à gauche
et nous les centristes les démocrates et
des modérés trouvons particulièrement
peu à nous exprimer nous aimer c'est que
cette année que le centrisme n'est pas
du tout acceptable télévision française
vous êtes
vous inviter à ces avec nous puisque on
va aborder donc sept autres thèmes de
l'actualité sans doute peut-être plus
préjudiciable à en ce moment pour
l'exécutif la gestion du protocole
sanitaire à l'école et la grève massif
qui se profile jeudi c'est donc la
polémique du jour et emmanuel macron a
réagi d'ailleurs un peu plus tôt à
l'appel à cette grève des enseignants
une mobilisation prévue jeudi donc dont
les établissements scolaires je vous
propose d'écouter
les gouvernements à ajuster
continue d'accompagner la politique
sanitaire à l'école pour essayer de la
rendre plus simple est viable pour les
pour les familles et les enseignants
je crois fondamentalement que le choix
que nous avons fait de maintenir l'école
ouverte et le bon choix il ya une
injustice profonde quand on ferme
l'école on va donc en parler du
ras-le-bol du monde enseignant avec
cette grève à venir on en parle avec
vous dans cette seconde partie et nous a
rejoint donc sur ce plateau en direct
najat belkacem un co président de la
fcpe premier syndicat des parents d
élèves
merci nous rejoindre najat belkacem
emmanuel macron te comprend donc la
lassitude vous vous sentez compris vous
en ce moment les parents d'élèves
je m'étais évidemment que nous on ne se
sent pas compris sinon on n'aurait pas
appelé à soutenir ce mouvement
national jeudi bien évidemment ce que ce
que l'on comprend on ne comprend pas
s'il va nous notre intérêt c'est bien
évidemment les écoles restent ouvertes 1
on est des parents à vantoux nous ne
sommes pas un syndicat nous sommes une
association de parents donc on
représente des usagers de l'école donc
ce que ce qui nous intéresse surtout
c'est que les moyens soient mises en
place dans les écoles pour justement
garantir que ces écoles restent ouvertes
or aujourd'hui on le voit bien il ya des
casse-tête de protocole qui se met en
place il y en a ce matin j'écoutais il y
en a 49 qui sont mis depuis le début de
la pandémie quarante neuf protocoles qui
ont eu lieu à l'école depuis depuis le
début donc vous voyez bien que la des
casse tête ça n'arrête pas la semaine
dernière on a vécu ce que nous nous
appelons le summum des protocoles où les
familles se sont retrouvées à aller
devoir aller travailler revenir chercher
leur enfant allait les faire tester
faire une heure et demie de queue pour
aller pour pouvoir tester leurs enfants
les ramener à l'école sur le droit de
voir une grille les enseignants absents
repartir après avoir des autotests kiné
qui n'était pas dans les pharmacies
enfin voilà tout ça a fait que
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on en a un peu
marre et la situation on l'a vécu
pendant un an et demi deux ans
aujourd'hui on a joué le jeu on a joué
le jeu de la de l'école à la maison on a
joué le jeu et les adolescents sont
vaccinés en majorité aujourd'hui on en a
un que oui ras-le-bol alors avant de
faire nos invités on va écouter jean
castex sur ce casse tête justement sans
mauvais jeu de mots le premier ministre
à l'assemblée nationale cet après midi
si comme vous nous le suggérer
nous n'avions pas rouvert les écoles
lundi dernier ce qu tt une grave erreur
pensez vous qu avec 90 mille cas par
jour en l'horaire ouverte lundi à nos
quinquas et tout ceci se serait
prolongée au détriment des enfants de
france la priorité de la france en
particulier dans le secteur éducatif
sous l'égide et l'engagement du ministre
de l'éducation nationale c'est le plus
possible de laisser les écoles ouvertes
car rien n'est plus dramatique à court
et à long terme à court et à long terme
que de fermer nos écoles nous
revendiquons ce choix
najat belkacem qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez oui on a gardé les écoles
ouvertes c'est vrai que la france a
plutôt mieux réussi
sur ce point que beaucoup de pays mais
enfin ça vous console où vous trouvez
que finalement c'est pire
qu'à écouter chez nous on se positionne
pas si gris sur sur l'ouverture des
écoles je vous ai dit notre position est
très claire notre intérêt c'est que nos
enfants aillent suivre une scolarité
donc là-dessus il n'y a pas de ya pas de
doute possible auprès des parents là où
on se on se pose sérieusement des
questions c'est ok mais c'est les écoles
ouvertes coûte que coûte comme dirait le
président mais alors avec quels moyens
parce qu'aujourd'hui la réalité c'est
que pendant un an et demi on a vécu
cette pandémie et que la semaine
dernière un énième protocole arrivent
par voie de presse sans moyens parce que
les parents quand ils se sont retrouvés
devant les pharmacies il n'y avait pas
d'auto tests disponibles alors que le
protocole vous mais qu'on conteste les
enfants deux fois par auto test dans la
semaine donc aujourd'hui on ne comprend
plus pourquoi
l'exécutif ne met pas les moyens à
l'école pour protéger nos enfants
protégés sombre son personnel et donc en
installant des capteurs de co2 en
mettant des purificateurs d'air en
mettant des lave-mains éphémère aussi
pour les petits parce qu'on sait que les
petits les gestes barrières sont
essentiels tous ces moyens que nous nous
réclamons depuis quasiment le début de
la pandémie
rien quasiment neta par an dans les
écoles actuellement donc aujourd'hui on
se pose cette question là nous ils ont
quand même aussi vécu pendant un an et
demi la la pandémie avec dédé des
problèmes structurels qui était déjà
existantes qui se sont amplifiés
notamment le remplacement des
professeurs savez je je discutais avec
une maman pas plus tard que fin de
semaine dernière qui elle a pris un
nouveau travail est la seule peur
qu'elle avait c'était de devoir
récupérer ses enfants parce qu'elle est
en période de préavis et qu'elle a déjà
donné beaucoup de jours par rapport à
ces problématiques d'école voyez la peur
des français elle est là en fait
évidemment parmi les dames en sait il va
aller travailler il veut laisser des
deux écoles ouvertes mais ils veulent
qu'on leur donne les moyens que ça que
ce soit fut réellement france 3 3 baffes
quand vous entendez cette maman et c'est
vrai que les parents sont confrontés à
des situations ubuesques en tout comme
les directeurs et les enseignants on se
dit parfois le gouvernement est un peu
hors sol vous comprenez c'est à cette
colère honnêtement
ma barbe blanche je fais moi même père
de famille est par ailleurs j'en sais il
y en université depuis plus de trente
ans et j'ai des étudiants qui
malheureusement pour beaucoup ne sont
pas très en forme en ce moment je vous
rappelle simplement une chose l'om est
ce nous guy que dans deux mois la moitié
de la population européenne sera
contaminée par le coronavirus alors je
comprends en fait tout le monde est
crevé permettez moi cette familiarité
tous crever plus personne n'en peux plus
je le sais évidemment nous le savons
tous que nous sommes crever le problème
c'est comment fait-on pour résoudre tout
cela quand les enseignants sont sont
malades et comment fait-on pour les
remplacer par qui les en place dont on
ne peut pas mettre n'importe qui pour
garder nos enfants donc si vous voulez
le gouvernement parent au plus pressé
madame a raison quand on dit à quelqu'un
fait une heure et demie de queue devant
une pharmacie était mon père une journée
travail quand le gouvernement essaie de
s'adapter pour supprimer cette heure et
demie que on pare au plus pressé dans
une situation d'urgence ça ne sera
jamais satisfaisant est ce qu'on espère
c'est tenir les 2 3 les mois qui restent
jusqu'à l'été et puisse aller mieux mais
on se rend bien compte que former des
personnes pour garder nos enfants
ça demande beaucoup plus de temps qu'on
en a actuellement on ne peut pas confier
nos enfants orth qui est madame à réseau
il faut laisser on ne va pas non plus
confié nos enfants aux grands parents
ils vont attraper les coronavirus et
finir au cimetière ah si vous voulez il
faut être clair et concret en réalité et
s'adapter au jour le jour et c'est ce
que le gouvernement essaie de faire avec
des échecs oui je le reconnais mais bien
malin tu ferais mieux
monsieur je vous proposais une carte
chez nous parce que là ça fait quand
même plusieurs échecs que vous
reconnaissez du gouvernement et j'en
suis quand même ravi de cette lucidité
une chose
la seule chose qu'il n'avait pas loupé
c'était l'école il avait loupé les
masques il avait loupé les tests on
avait été en retard sur les vaccins la
seule chose qu'il n'avait pas loupé ils
n'ont vous paie et on aura fait le tour
de cette pandémie dans une ambiance
d'impréparation
d'amateurisme on avait suggéré notamment
avec valérie pécresse de faire en sorte
de repousser d'une semaine pour éviter
cela puisque toute façon on va être
clair avec la grève de jeudi est le fait
que bas le vendredi vous allez voir que
ça va être un peu pareil et qu'on aura
perdu énormément de temps et que des
genres ont perdu potentiellement leur
capacité à aller au boulot et c'est la
semaine on l'aura perdu ça nous aura
coûté de l'énervement de l'argent et de
l'impréparation et changer quelque chose
c'est bien sûr serait regardé cette
semaine si on avait mis en place assez
rapidement le décalage ça aurait permis
d'éviter ces couacs là serait permis par
exemple de bosser avec madame qui est
notre intervenante de bosser avec les
associations de parents d'élèves cela
j'ai eu la chance de travailler à
l'époque pour un ministre de l'éducation
qui s'appelle luc chatel je sais combien
c'est important de discuter avec les
associations de parents d'élèves avec
les syndicats et peut-être que si on
avait eu un exercice moins solitaire du
pouvoir un exercice qui soit -
autarcique du pouvoir on aurait
simplement convié ces associations pour
discuter avec elle est effectivement
vous l'auriez pas appris par voie de
presse et vous aurait été peut-être
embarqué dans cette décision et vous
auriez fait corriger potentiellement à
ce gouvernement qui n'entend rien un
certain nombre de mesures et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec le fait que ça
aura été réussi le gouvernement aura
loupé sur tous les tableaux alors bien
évidemment quand il s'agit d'envoyer des
chèques aux uns et aux autres c'est plus
facile de le faire et dans ce cas les
gens vous dire ah bah finalement moi mon
secteur a été épargné parce que j'ai
reçu un petit chèque mais ça s'appelle
pas une gestion s'appelle acheter des
voix et donc la préparation et
l'amateurisme on aura fait le tour on
aura fait deux ans dans lequel toutes
les cases auront été cochée ils se
seront louper najet belhassen le mot de
la fin pour vous un jean michel blanquer
requis qui disait ce matin chez nos
confrères de bfm on ne fait pas grève
contre un virus qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez parce qu'à part mettre des
purificateurs d'air qu est-ce qu
aujourd'hui on a du mal à le comprendre
demande les enseignants et les parents
d'élèves pour solutionner cette cette
situation compliquée effectivement
écoutez moi je je je me prononce son nom
des parents d'élèves je ne suis pas
voilà je ne suis pas enseignante voilà
je travaille par ailleurs donc je suis
bénévole dans cette association ça fait
un an et demi deux ans qu'on vit cette
grève et convie cette ce virus donc
aujourd'hui qu'on vienne pas nous dire
qu'on combat un virus on sait on sait
depuis un an et demi là ce que nous
reprochons
exactement à l'exécutif c'est la mise en
place de moyens pour le respect des
gestes barrière vous l'avez citer les
capteurs on nous renvoie aux
collectivités les collectivités nous
renvoie à l'état donc nous on se
retrouve entre les deux le les
purificateurs d'air on a des fenêtres
qui n'ouvrait pas dans les classes ça
c'est une réalité c'est très
terre-à-terre les tests salivaires les
tests salivaires je suis désolé mais
vous êtes vous avez dit bon exactement
vous êtes tous quasiment par an vous
savez que des tests avec le goupillon
dans le nez pour trois fois par semaine
on sait très bien que les adultes auront
du mal à le supporter alors vous je vous
raconte même pas pour les enfants donc
les tests salivaires où sont ils pour
les plus petits tout ça et puis des
points aussi de test aux abords des
écoles on en a discuté avec monsieur
blanc caire la semaine dernière nous
étions en réunion avec lui nous lui
avons dit la semaine dernière installer
des points de test aux abords des écoles
vous voyez bien que ça ne j'suis pas le
système dont des sites ou à la dernière
minute on met en place sans moyens ça ne
marche pas donc faisons en sorte
aujourd'hui d'un en effet laisser les
écoles ouvertes mais avec des moyens
supplémentaires mon matériel team merci
beaucoup nage adresse à sa merci
également à genas raddad sorte ce
plateau et air france soit rob huff
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir et
les enseignants les enseignants qui
feront donc entendre leur voix jeudi à
on lisait en attendant aujourd'hui ces
deux secteurs médico-social qui a
exprimé son ras-le-bol mobilisation à
l'appel de la cgt un peu partout en
france des soignants sages femmes
professionnelles de la petite enfance ou
encore des ehpad sont descendus dans la
rue manifestation pour demander de
meilleures conditions de travail notre
reporter david khalifa était dans le
cortège parisien cet après midi un appel
intersyndical national aujourd'hui un
millier de personnes réunies dans la rue
cet après midi pour dénoncer la
stratégie sanitaire du gouvernement qui
consiste à laisser circuler massivement
le virus pour maintenir coûte que coûte
l'activité économique à pari osé pour
ces soignants et ses aides soignants qui
sont est en première ligne pour cette
cinquième vague ducobu 19 assez un
virulent tu plusieurs revendications des
revendications qu'on a l'habitude
d'entendre un depuis maintenant deux ans
l'augmentation du budget à des hôpitaux
la reconnaissance et la revalorisation
des carrières médical et non médical le
recrutement de centaines de milliers de
professionnels supplémentaires et
surtout l'arrêt de fermeture de lits en
france depuis le début de l'épidémie
ducobu 19 le commis 19 qui n'a fait que
renforcer les conséquences des choix
politiques faits depuis 20 ans dans le
viseur un de ces à la soignant et cf
soignant notamment le ségur de la santé
écouter des professionnels ne voient pas
le bout du tunnel et surtout ils n'ont
pas de perspective on a un gouvernement
qui ne s'exprime toujours pas sur la
nécessité en tout cas de recruter du
personnel et de former massivement du
personnel et les professionnels
attendent toujours des revalorisations
salariales digne de notre pays puisque
tous les pays européens rémunère mieux
leurs professionnels il faut vraiment un
choc d'attractivité en tout cas pour
voir un hôpital public et pour les
établissements du sanitaire du social et
du médico social
sinon nous n'aurons plus de pères et de
professionnels dans les prochaines
semaines et c'est vrai que c'est très
difficile pour les professionnels de
fait projeter alors qu'il n'ya pas de
reconnaissance tangible de ce
gouvernement les systèmes de santé il
est débordé actuellement il est au bord
de l'effondrement et c'est pas parce que
macron s'amuse à emmerder les
non-vaccinés que en fait ça change
quelque chose nous n'avons ni postes
supplémentaires ni moyen supplémentaire
ni budget supplémentaire d'aucune sorte
donc on se demande qui en merki moi je
vais vous donner la réponse c'est merci
monsieur macron et son gouvernement et
tous ses playmobil qui vote qui nous
supprime tous les ans tous les jours de
l'argent pour avoir des postes des
soignants et du matériel supplémentaire
des représentants politiques étaient
également présents au sein du cortège un
pour venir soutenir cette mobilisation
notamment adrien à 80 députés la france
insoumise qui dénonce l'inaction du
gouvernement écouter ça fait deux ans
maintenant que le personnel de santé est
mis à rude épreuve avec la situation
sanitaire je rappelle qu'avant même
l'épidémie il était en manifestations
pour réclamer des moyens supplémentaires
et que l'épidémie aura vu arriver le
ségur de la santé dont tout le monde
voit qu'il est rudement insuffisant il
ya des revendications qui sont sur la
table depuis maintenant plus de deux ans
une véritable revalorisation du point
d'indicé pour les salaires des
recrutements la hauteur des besoins des
besoins humains qui sont colossaux au
moment où l'épidémie repart de plus
belle
qu'on arrête la fermeture des lits parce
que vous savez que monsieur macron à
fermer beaucoup de 5900 de plus alors
qu'il avait dit la santé n'a pas de prix
on arrête de considérer l'hôpital comme
une entreprise en fait on voit que tout
cela continue et donc on leur doit
beaucoup en réalité c'est celles et ceux
qui nous soigne aujourd'hui qui soigne
nos proches dans cette situation
épidémique et donc on à leurs côtés pour
soutenir leurs revendications et on sera
toujours là le cortège a terminé sa
course aux invalides une audience a été
demandée à à l'exécutif audience refusé
l'objectif pour les soignants et les
aides soignants évidemment demandé de
véritables négociations pour que
l'hôpital public ne meurt pas d'ici les
prochaines années
est la lutte contre le coronavirus sur
le vieux continent et l'inquiétude qui
grandit plus de la moitié des européens
seront touchés par micron d'ici deux
mois voilà la malheureuse prédictions de
nos ms aujourd'hui l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui réclament des
vaccins anti kovy pour réduire les
risques de transmission plutôt que la
stratégie actuelle visant à administrer
des doses de rappel jugé non viable
à ce rythme l'institut de mesure et
d'évaluation de la santé prévoit que
plus de 50 % de la population de
l'europe on sera infecté par omicron
dans les six à huit prochaines semaines
50 des 53 pays d'europe et d'asie
centrale ont désormais signaler des
cadeaux mikron il devient rapidement le
virus d'ogm en a en europe occidentale
et se propage maintenant dans les
balkans into et à coller les données
rassemblées ces dernières semaines
confirme comique rhône et hautement
transmissible
car les mutations qu'il présente lui
permettent d'adhérer plus facilement aux
cellules humaines et il peut infecter
même les personnes qui ont été
préalablement infectés ou vaccinés ou
rapide priestly une fête est le
gouvernement britannique pointé du doigt
dans sa stratégie sanitaire depuis le
début de la pandémie boris johnson fait
régulièrement la une des au royaume uni
avec des scandales à répétition dernier
en date une fête organisée dans le
jardin de sa résidence en mai 2020 une
quarantaine de personnes avaient été
conviées à ce repas du premier ministre
britannique moment même le pays était
confiné pour lutter contre le coc vide
cinq réceptions du même qui font déjà
l'objet d'une enquête et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis liverpool
au royaume uni avec francesco rizzuto
doyen de la faculté de droit à
l'université de liverpool ro c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir
francesco rizzotto merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france boris
johnson qui est donc soupçonné d'avoir
participé à cette fête en compagnie de
son épouse le 20 mai 2020 c'est la fête
de trop
c'est une excellente question
vous avez peut-être bien raison
la chambre des communes aujourd'hui a
été le théâtre de scènes extraordinaires
il a disparaît à noël en espérant que la
situation
se calmera
[Musique]
je pense que la publication de
ce dernier mais là vraiment ouvert la
boîte de pandore donc je pense que cela
pourrait susciter le gros problème pour
lui notamment dans les sondages alors
effectivement les révélations ont déjà
fait aller les unes de la presse
britannique avec notamment le hashtag
partie gates clairement francesco
rizzotto ça peut lui coûter son poste on
imagine que les britanniques n'apprécie
pas vraiment à vue le bilan lourd a dû
qu'ovide également dans votre pays
avec l'équipe des blacks est pénalisant
c'est ce que le public est effectivement
scolarisés
mais que je parle dans les médias
d'individus après individus qui est avec
le confinement n'ont pas pu rendre
visite à leurs parents leurs compagnons
qui était sur le lit de mort et pendant
ce temps fort et johnson faisait la fête
au numéro 10 rue dans une stricte
le choc l'indignation est palpable dans
le pays et lorsqu'on voit des
députés
conservateurs pleurer au parlement c'est
une scène vraiment choquant
je les ai tous
les sondages depuis
cinquante-six pour cent des personnes
questionnées je voulais qu'il
démissionne et seuls 27 % souhaitent
qu'il ne démissionne pas
en tant que les premiers ministres
c'est du vent mais tout cela dépend de
ce que les députés destructions nettes
et cela dépendra de la pression
appliquée par leurs électeurs donc les
semaines à venir seront cruciales ça
veut dire quoi pour le renverser qu'on
comprenne bien il faut un vote de
défiance au sein du parti conservateur
ça suffirait
chiffres il faut numbers aussi à 54 12
membres du parlement
tout adressé une lettre à ce qu'on
appelle le comité
92,1 gahler il y aura une élection
pour choisir
un nouveau chef du parti
premier ministre au même titre qu'il est
chef du parti conservateur
si boris johnson perd cette élection à
la tête du parti conservateur alors il
doit également démissionner en tant que
premier ministre car il ne bénéficie
plus dans la confiance de des députés
conservateurs et il y aurait donc un
nouveau chef du parti qui serait
également une nouveau premier ministre
mais nous avons déjà assisté un scénario
semblable parce que theresa may a perdu
un vote a dû démissionner et avait été
remplacé par boris johnson il y a deux
ans maintenant
il n'y aurait pas d'élection il y aurait
pas d'élections en tout cas au niveau du
pays il s'agirait d'un
sujet interne au parti j'espère que cela
fait sens francesco fait de ton on a
parlé de ces fêtes évidemment qui font
désordre en pleine pandémie il n'empêche
ça on se souvient des débuts chaotiques
au royaume uni à un bilan lourd on se
souvient de ses excuses solennelles à la
télévision du premier ministre mais on
se souvient aussi d'une campagne
vaccinale plutôt mieux réussi aux
départs en tout cas du royaume uni
ça ça n'est pas amis au crédit par les
britanniques de boris johnson
je confirme et met effectivement à son
crédit de
l'industrie de l'éducation a par exemple
les communs des
lions donne ce crédit d'avoir lancé la
campagne par exemple que le rappelle
jean notre côté de professeurs
fonctionnaires
et souffert de cette pandémie
aujourd'hui sur 4 379 personnes sont
d'origine donc il faudrait qu'une mairie
s'agit vraiment d'une situation
partagée il ya donc cette campagne de
rappel contre l'idée d'imprimer les
manettes
je pense que
nation ne veut pas le premier ministre
malhonnête ce qu'il ne dit pas la vérité
dans ce job et un bus est le seul coûte
un premier ministre qui agissent comme
si lui même s'était au dessus de la
loire il est vital pour toute démocratie
que l'alien s'applique également à
l'effet que tout le monde quelle que
soit leur position dans la société et je
pense que cela est que tous les ans et
les succès de pression sinon je porte
quel écran qui a voulu suisse et a
détaillé dans certains domaines
pourraient faire accuser tout langage de
briser le suspense la
fabrique constitutionnel merci beaucoup
francesco raid auto d'avoir été avec
nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir
et autres dossiers incontournables
l'actualité étrangère dominée par la
situation notamment au kazakhstan avec
un retour à l'apaisement plus d'une
semaine après les émeutes meurtrières le
président a nommé un premier ministre il
avait limogé le précédent gouvernement
après les violences à l'origine de la
colère des casaques la hausse des prix
du carburant aujourd'hui le président
accuse son prédécesseur d'être
responsable de ces émeutes parlant de
une tentative de coup d'état
grâce au premier président le chef de la
nation un groupe d'entreprises très
rentable et une caste de riches même
selon les normes internationales sont
apparus dans le pays
je pense que le moment est venu de payer
un tribut au peuple kazakh et de l'aider
de manière systématique et régulière
par conséquent le gouvernement devra
déterminer l'éventail des entreprises et
convenir avec elle du montant des
contributions annuelles au fonds de
solidarité j'attends également une
participation active de ces personnes
possédant des fonds énormes et qui sont
cachés dans l'ombre
et pour venir à la rescousse du
kazakhstan le président a demandé l aide
de la russie une opération de maintien
de la paix pour sécuriser les lieux
sensibles
suite au retour au calme les militaires
doivent se retirer dès jeudi et de façon
progressive
envoyé spécial darty international
mourad gaz df se trouve dans la région
d'almaty où il a suivi certains de ses
soldats
puisque
l'opération de maintien de la paix ici
au kazakhstan bat son plein tout le
monde est déjà arrivé les gens ont pris
leurs positions prévu et les sécurise
comme l'a fait ce détachement biélorusse
près de l'aéroport qui a initialement
été le point d'entrée pour les soldats
de la paix
lors des émeutes de la semaine dernière
une quantité inconnue d'armes dont des
mitrailleuses et des lance grenades ont
été saisies par des pillards parmi ces
pillards il y avait des extrémistes
le gouvernement l'a confirmé des
djihadistes avec des années d'expérience
de combat
ce site est stratégique pour notre unité
nous avons reçu l'ordre d'empêcher
l'incursion de formations armées
ennemies nous essayons de nous y
conformer
les soldats de la paix ont été chargés
de protéger les infrastructures clés des
contingents de tous les états membres de
l'ôter ac qui ont été déployées dans des
zones cruciales pour aider une armées
kazakhes surchargé qu'il s'agisse de
base militaire de bureaux
gouvernementaux ou même de centrales
électriques
un autre site clé où la sécurité a été
renforcée par les soldats de la paix et
la centrale électrique qui alimente la
ville d'almaty en chauffage et en
électrique
ici le bataillon kirghize a pris le
contrôle
une brigade kirghize ap les scorpions
assure la sécurité ici
70% de l'électricité à almaty et
produite par cette station et compte
tenu de la façon dont les maraudeurs et
les bandits cible est systématiquement
les infrastructures les travailleurs ici
penser qu'ils seraient les prochains
au début de ces émeutes le personnel ne
se sentait pas en sécurité
il avait peur mais après l'arrivée des
forces de maintien de la paix nous
sommes protégés car ceci est une zone
stratégique
la sécurité a été largement renforcé les
patrouilles sont partout et il ya même
des mots de passe secret pour détecter
les agents infiltrés la nuit un mot de
passe est nécessaire et ici avec la
police qui protège les postes nous
exigeons que les travailleurs limitent
leurs déplacements
certaines de ces mesures peuvent
paraître excessive ou même être
excessive mais les gens ici sont encore
sous le choc les soldats de la paix sont
un point d'ancrage il représente la
sécurité l'ordre les deux choses dont
les gens le plus besoin ici
need et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexandre del valle géopolitologue
écrivain auteur de la mondialisation
dangereuse aux éditions de l'artilleur
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous le
président donc qui sont les prix
aujourd'hui à son précis puissant à
prédécesseur il accuse d'avoir favorisé
l'émergence d'une caste de richesse que
7,7 une accusation qui est fondée selon
vous
je n'ai pas les détails mais qu il est
vrai que l'ancien président avait
instauré un pouvoir personnel est assez
autoritaire lié à aucune pouvoir
oligarchique et c'est une lapalissade
que de dire qu'il existe une oligarchie
encore en partie vie à l'ancien
président qui a longtemps régné qui a
mis tous ces gens en place et il est
vrai aussi que les troubles imputés à
des un terrorisme international par les
ou à l'occident par les autres ce sont
essentiellement des troubles entre un
ancien président et son successeur ce
dernier n'ayant pas réussi à acquérir
toute la légitimité et la popularité
nécessaire et ayant un peu échappé à non
pas à l'ancien mais à la clique et au
pouvoir oligarchique qui étaient autour
de de l'ancien président est forcément
cette clique veut rester en place c'est
quelle configuration assez classique
dans une succession qui se passe mal et
un est indicible qui échappe à son
créateur ça veut dire en gros affaire
interne au pays fin de l'histoire
en fait c'est comme en médecine ils
seront plusieurs paramètres qui se
croisent il y a cette dimension que je
me décrire il y à aussi effectivement ce
qui n'est pas tout à fait infondées même
si c'est un prétexte en partie invoqué
par les membres de l'ocf l'organisation
à conférence de shanghai qui a été créé
d'ailleurs en 2001 pour combattre
officiellement entre autres le
terrorisme islamiste et pour instaurer
alors multipolaire avec le kazakhstan
est un pays très stratégique dans
l'alliance de shanghai et il est vrai
aussi que le kazakhstan comme
l'ouzbékistan
comme tous ces pays
turcophones d'asie centrale mais
l'azerbaïdjan un peu de côté sont
menacés on pourrait parler aussi d'un
pays non turcophone le tadjikistan mais
ces pays d'asie centrale ex soviétique
sont très menacés par des mouvements
islamistes radicaux liés au terrorisme
international d'al qaïda ou de dèche et
un peu les deux maintenant et c'est que
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement ont
connu l'un des membres fondateurs l'un
des groupes fondateurs d'al qaïda dans
les années 80-90 était le mouvement
islamique de l'ouzbékistan qui est très
présent dans toute l'asie centrale et
ces pays sont marqués par la laïcité
marxiste par une anti religieuse ite et
un traitement impitoyable des islamistes
qui ont été réprimées dans tous ces pays
et il est vrai que quand il ya des
troubles internes et bien des mouvements
islamistes peuvent être tentés de se
greffer sur un trouble comme on l'a vu
dans un an très différent au mali où des
laïcs berbères ont été rejoints par des
djihadistes et donc c'est par
entièrement faux de dire qu'il ya des
menaces terroristes islamistes qui n'a
jamais supporté c'est pouvoir laïque
liés à la russie est héritée de l'ex
soviétisme marxiste alors on voit que
l'europe réagit à rapper aujourd'hui au
respect de la souveraineté du pays au
respect des droits de l'homme des
diplomaties américaine aussi qui a donné
son opinion
est ce que l'europe l'occident d'une
manière générale à la bonne lecture de
ce qui s'est passé au kazakhstan selon
vous non je ne suis pas sûr aujourd'hui
il y à un prisme tout ce qui est dans
l'alliance trop russe ou trop chinoise
ou
ocs l'alliance de shanghai donc tous
ceux qui sont proches en gros de l'ex
monde soviétique et de la russie mais
aussi de la chine qui est également très
proche du kazakhstan on pourrait dire un
bloc soviétique ou ex communistes aux
communistes et bien tout ce qui vient de
ces pays est systématiquement considérés
comme suspects comme faut tout ce que
disent ses dirigeants sont tous tués
toujours considérés comme faux il ya
quand même un prisme un peu guerre
froide ça n'empêche pas que dans ces
pays il a des dictateurs absolument pas
mon propos de le nier mais il y à une
suspicion de principe et quoique c'est
comme quand il ya un meurtre en russie
c'est forcément poutine quand même si en
fait parfois c'est peut être une machine
il ya un a priori et ça ça peut empêcher
une lecture saine que de ne pas voir la
complexité il peut y avoir un peu de ça
mais il ya aussi d'autres paramètres une
instabilité menace islamiste et rory est
aussi un problème d'inégalité de
pauvreté le kazakhstan est un des pays
les plus riches du monde avec des mines
et des réserves d'hydrocarbures mais
aussi avec aussi alors qu'à pas une
énorme population c'est une très faible
densité mais en même temps avec des gens
très pauvres et qui ont été approuvés et
encore plus depuis la crise qu vidée
depuis la hausse des prix des
hydrocarbures donc ce que l'occident ne
voit pas donc son moralisme qui pointent
toujours les mêmes c'est qu' il peut y
avoir cela mais il ya aussi d'autres
paramètres et c'est dommage d'oublier
d'autres paramètres y compris des
rivalités à entre ces ces méchants des
spots que l'occident conspué eux ils
sont pas toujours d'accord entre eux et
moi je pense que la vraie grille de
lecture c'est c'est cette opposition
entre
un président et son successeur c'est la
csé greffer là-dessus le problème des
inégalités qui réel et qui qui depuis
des années a été touché par le régime
quand même assez autoritaire c'est
pourquoi alexandre del valle de nous
avoir apporté votre analyse est resté
avec mon dans quelques instants nous
parlerons des parrainages pour
l'élection présidentielle en france à
trois mois du scrutin certains candidats
ne sont toujours pas sûrs de pouvoir y
participer faute des fameuses 500
signatures pour le gouvernement de
question de changer les règles alors le
système de parrainage et ils obsolète on
est en train d'y voir plus clair
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
le new york times le washington post the
world
girls go
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'afrique regorge de richesses mais ne
représentent que 3% du pib mondial en
2021 propre à l'afrique hors transports
un petit peu ces matières premières le
problème n'est pas technique c'est un
manque de prise de conscience collectif
des dirigeants havrais c'est tout un
ensemble de chaînes des gens qui vont
s'accaparer au pouvoir et la richesse
qui valent la gabégie des hommes d'état
ont l'associent à ce système aussi de la
françafrique la françafrique tout le
monde est au courant maintenant il
s'agit d'un clone d'ésotérique de
pouvoir d'argent pour ensemble trouver
un système de rente est par définition
de nombreuses distributions aux
populations il s'agit de venir prendre à
la source quelque chose le problème de
fond c'est curieux c'est la façon dont
on le prend
[Musique]
un certain nombre de journalistes eux
semblent s'être octroyé à un pouvoir de
juger un pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens
cherchent et j'ai essayé de trouver des
réponses mais l étrave ainsi jamais à
oger une qualité ou une compétence ou
une expertise que je n'avais pas je
pense que notre métier devrait un peu
douté de ses bases et les revoir et les
remettre en question l'a toujours eu un
rôle historique pour le meilleur et pour
le pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était
un petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio puis toutes les choses graves
j'ai l'impression qu'on les apprend par
la radio quand on écoute la radio on
sait si c'est grave ou si c'est pas
grave plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire j - 10 89 avant la
présidentielle et si jean luc mélenchon
marine le pen ou encore eric zemmour ne
pouvait finalement pas se présenter ses
trois candidats s'inquiètent en tout cas
faute de parrainages suffisants à ce
jour ils demandent l'anonymat des élus
attendant leur signature pour le
gouvernement hors de question de changer
les règles et vous qu'en pensez-vous le
système de parrainage et ils obsolète on
attend vos réactions sur notre compte et
les graves
[Musique]
emmanuel macron a présenté ses voeux à
la presse ce soir on en parlait tout à
l'heure mais tarde à se déclarer
officiellement candidat alors que la
présidentielle aura lieu dans moins de
trois mois maintenant d'autres candidats
se sont lancés officiellement dans la
course à l'elysée mais peine encore à
réunir les fameuses 500 signatures
nécessaires c'est le cas notamment
d'eric zemmour demain il le pen de jean
luc mélenchon tous trois dénonce un
système actuel qu'il juge
antidémocratique le gouvernement lui ne
semble pas disposée à changer les choses
nicolas petit
avant de devenir le porte parole du
gouvernement
gabriel attal est lui aussi passé par là
en 2016 pour trouver les 500 parrainages
liées à la candidature d'emmanuel macron
lui même a reconnu ce mardi être allé
les chercher avec les dents alors que
plusieurs voix s'élèvent pour rendre
anonymes les parrainages gabriela talent
n'a aucunement l'intention d'y répondre
favorablement
à chaque élection on entend ce débat on
entend des candidats dire qu'ils ne sont
pas sûrs d'avoir leur parrainage et
finalement il y arrive un certain nombre
d'entre eux ont déjà été candidat à
l'élection présidentielle et ont eu
leurs parrainages il y à 40000 personnes
qui peuvent parrainer il faut 500
parrainages j'ai assez peu de doute sur
le fait que les candidats qui
s'expriment auront trouvé leur
parrainage
contrairement à la présidentielle de
2017 jean luc mélenchon ne bénéficient
pas cette fois du soutien du parti
communiste d'après le candidat de la
france insoumise la partie est loin
d'être gagnée alors à laquelle je vous
parle j'approche les 400 signatures mais
ce n'est pas cinq sens et il ne me reste
que 50 jours cinquante quatre jours pour
parvenir à avoir des promesses qui
ensuite se traduirait en déclaration au
conseil constitutionnel je demande
rendez vous avec le président du sénat
gérard larcher
parce que le sénat est dans les
institutions et dans la coutume
française le représentant des
collectivités locales un message entendu
par le président du sénat également
président du comité de soutien de
valérie pécresse jean luc mélenchon
marine le pen eric zemmour qui
représente une part significative de
l'opinion doivent pouvoir se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle
je souhaite que les élus utilisent
pleinement leurs droits de parrainage
qu'ils le fassent sans crainte je
parrainerait valérie pécresse mais je ne
ferai pas de procès d'intention à un élu
qui ferait un autre choix anne hidalgo
qui de son côté a très rapidement obtenu
ces 500 parrainages ne partage pas cette
vision des choses bien que les sondages
créditent marine le pen et eric zemmour
de plus de 10% des intentions de vote
la candidate socialiste estime que s'ils
ne parviennent pas à obtenir leur
signature cela signifie qu'ils ne
méritent pas de participer au scrutin et
dans ce cas c'est je cite tant pis pour
eux
alors question faut-il revoir le système
de parrainage et ils obsolète certains
candidats ont-ils a raison de demander
l'anonymat des élus signataires on
attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme daté france et c'est l'heure
de notre décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau alexis poulin et ans et liszt rt
france dont on a entendu le rire
communicatif vous parlez de circulation
à paris quel moment c'est un petit peu
notre perception habituelle lé petit
poulain bonsoir son côté denis de mon
option éditorialiste politique bonsoir
vous aussi merci d'être leur marine le
pen un bon ça on a l'habitude c'est un
petit peu à chaque élection qu'elle
s'inquiète fortement de des parrainages
mais rejoint par jean luc mélenchon eric
zemmour est ce qu'ils ont raison de
véritablement s'inquiéter de cette
récolte des 500 signatures où il ya un
peu des monts fait ça se finit toujours
finalement bien des couches alors il ya
toujours un peu d'esbroufé c'est le
moment où il est question de rameuter
les troupes de faire un dernier baroud
d'honneur de faire aussi de la com 1 sur
sa candidature d'assurer que les
militants sont mobilisés pour la
campagne est donc c'est la dernière
ligne droite donc généralement quand on
commence à dire qu'on n'a pas vraiment
les signatures on les a quasiment mais
il s'agit de le dire et de s'assurer
d'avoir bien plus que 500 parce que il
suffirait d'une défection et là ce
serait effectivement un accident après
cette règle des 500 signatures c'est sûr
que elle pose question surtout avec la
réforme de françois hollande qui fait
que maintenant les signatures des élus
et des maires sont devenues publiques ce
qui n'était pas le cas auparavant ce qui
permettait de jouer sur la diversité
démocratique en donnant une signature en
disant je suis pas forcément d'accord
avec vous mais je défends la démocratie
et le pluralisme donc je vous donne ma
signature aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
plus difficile d'assumer puisque la
signature est publique et puis à la
question évidemment de
des règles qui peuvent être changées à
la dernière minute on voit gérald
darmanin mise de l'intérieur qui
rencontre le conseil constitutionnel
pour voir si l'élection les modalités
d'élection pouvait être aménagés
entendre que vides pour assurer la
meilleure éducation possible au mois
d'avril donc on voit bien que les
changements de dernière minute sont
possibles tout est possible en réalité
tout comme la proportionnelle donc
toutes ces règles qui sont imposés
qu'ils sont gardés par le temple
pourrait être changée pour plus de
démocratie et c'est vrai que ces
candidats aujourd'hui se disent pourquoi
on continue de suivre ça jean luc
mélenchon lui proposer un parrainage
populaire de 150 mille signatures on
voit qu'il ya des primaires qui seront
faits un succès et à droite chez les
écologistes également il ya d'autres
façon peut-être d'assurer la légitimité
d'un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle que ses 500 signatures on
vous parlait donc d'anonymat c'est ce
que demande de plusieurs de ses
candidats qui n'ont pas encore reçu leur
parrainage vous propose justement
d'écouté laurent jacot béni un porte
parole
il est compliqué pour les candidats
d'avoir leurs 500 signatures cela avance
mais c'est extrêmement compliqué il faut
que les parrainages soit anonyme les
noms des élus doivent rester anonyme
certains maires se demande s'il n'y aura
pas de conséquences on ne peut pas
empêcher les candidats légitimes d'être
présent à l'élection présidentielle
denis demonpion c'est depuis cette
réforme dont parlait
l'anonymat existait déjà avant puis en
fait son ascèse puisque les les
candidats avaient la possibilité de
recevoir d'ailleurs plus de 500
parrainages il y avait un tirage au sort
qui étaient effectués et ce tirage au
sort était évidemment les 500 parrains
et marraines fait était publié au
journal officiel mais ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est à dire avec la
multiplicité des modes de communication
des médias évidemment il ya une plus
grande curiosité et donc la
discrétion sur les noms des des fameux
parent évidemment n'a plus lieu d'être
quoi mais alors là quand on assiste
cette espèce de
psychodrame si on peut dire des
candidats en disant voilà on n'a pas nos
500 signatures il faut quand même
rappeler une chose c'est que on est le
11 janvier c'est à partir du 30 janvier
jusqu'au 4 mars que les candidats
pourront véritablement
se plaindre de ne pas avoir de
confortables tout de même c'est vrai que
quand on mène campagne ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent
n'est pas confortable ne pas savoir si
oui ou non on salue c'est de ces
plaintes ne sont pas nouvelles on voit
ça chaque élection c'est avait commencé
avec jean marie le pen il ya des années
et c'est une façon de dire voyez on est
les moutons noirs et on voit là le jeu
démocratique ne fonctionne pas avec nous
jusqu'à plus ample informé marine le pen
a toujours eu ses parrainages jean luc
mélenchon aussi et puis quand on prend
des candidats ou si j'allais dire
absent dans la campagne est mineur que
monsieur la salle jean lassalle il a
toujours eu ces ses parrainages pour se
présenter donc là il ya un jeu politique
plutôt
gauche au centre contre les droites où
les droites dures il n'empêche alexis
poulain il ya l'inconnue zemmour a c'est
vrai que et eghezée moore peut-être
clivant comme l'a peut-être été
effectivement jean marie le pen en son
temps il est encore un peu marine le pen
il ya ce risque
effectivement qu'on y ait des pressions
pour zemmour alors oui non puisqu'on
apprend aussi également quelques
tractations ou des idées ou de manière
très stratégique pour jouer aux échecs
les républicains ont intérêt à favoriser
la candidature d'eric zemmour pour faire
baisser marine le pen d'une certaine
façon donc les parties aussi joue de ces
candidatures pour appuyer l'un ou
l'autre des candidats qui vont permettre
de capter des voix ou d'enlever donc
c'est vrai que ce qui peut poser
problème c'est quand on a par exemple un
candidat comme fabien roussel du parti
communiste qui dit attention tous les
élus communistes doivent parrainer
uniquement le candidat communiste là
évidemment on va fermer le jeu et ça va
devenir compliqué on peut être
communiste est aussi avoir des affinités
avec des membres de la famille de gauche
va pas leur soutien comme on peut être
républicain et avoir des affinités avec
les idées d'eric zemmour et dire bah moi
je préfère parrainer eric zemmour que
valérie pécresse on voit bien d'ailleurs
la défection guillaume pelletier n'est
pas pour rien on a vu aussi le l'angle
d'eric ciotti pendant cette primaire
donc c'est tout à fait possible je crois
qu'eric zemmour n'aura pas de problème
d'avoir les 500 signatures après c'est
vrai que vous avez des élus qui ont
c'était le cas de françois fillon plus
de 3000 parrainage sur les cinq sens là
c'est très à l'aise et d'autres qui sont
à
585 162 c'est très différent justement
on va voir là un premier une première
réaction télégramme inde etienne qui
nous dit tout ce système est obsolète
qui croient encore en cette farce appelé
démocratique des élus de ce système dit
démocrate ici nous ont déjà des classes
est réduit à une caste d'intouchables
denis demonpion c'est vrai que ça donne
peut-être
cette impression parce que quand on voit
qu'une anne hidalgo qui peine à l'est
sur les 5 % je prends 2000 parrainage
c'est vrai qu'elle représente la partie
établie depuis longtemps et que certains
petit candidat 3 on rappelle que les
trois intéressés la pèse 40% dans les
sondages n'ont pas de signature c'est
vrai qu'on peut crier au scandale
démocratique
c'est peut-être scandale c'est peut-être
un peu fort parce que bon vous pouvoir
est vincent il se trouve que l'idée
bénéficie effectivement
du soutien et surtout deux
du parti socialiste qui a de nombreux
élus
donc évidemment ça lui est facile pour
elle étant donné qu' il ya quand même
beaucoup de municipalités aux dernières
élections qui ont été remportées par le
parti socialiste non c'est vrai que le
sol qui est dans une situation
singulière c'est eric zemmour puisque il
est candidat pour la première fois il
vient de créer son parti il est un petit
peu dans la même situation qui manuel
macron à la différence quand même c'est
que emmanuel macron était quand même un
homme d'appareil avait été ministre et
le fréquenta peut-être aussi et
peut-être pas fréquentable ont enfin il
n'avait pas du tout mais c'est vrai
qu'il était du sérail c'était quelqu'un
du sérail donc saluer été beaucoup plus
facile de recueillir les suffrages c'est
clair mais en tout cas
ce système de parrainage il faut quand
même rappeler que ça existe depuis
1962 c'est à dire depuis que le
président de la république est élu au
suffrage universel direct et
quand
michel debré à l'époque qui a été
premier ministre l'auteur de la
constitution une premier ministre du
général de gaulle avait instauré alors à
l'époque c'était 100 parrainages c'était
pour limiter le nombre de candidats et
surtout empêcher les candidatures
fantaisistes
voilà bien parce que aujourd'hui il
savait il ya
15 avec emmanuel macron qui n'est pas
tout à fait déclaré mais enfin il est
déjà en pleine campagne
vous avez donc quinze candidats qui
iront jusqu'au bout vraisemblablement à
peu de choses près mais vous avez par
ailleurs 26 candidats qui sont candidats
à la candidature
parmi eux vous avez gaspard koenig qui
est un essayiste à dire aujourd'hui être
un étudiant qui
se veut réécrire la constitution exion à
laurent oui vous avez également eric
drew et vous savez qui était une figure
des gilets jaunes bon alors est-ce
qu'ils ont les reins suffisamment
solides pour
animer une campagne présidentielle ils
sont seuls j'allais dire au monde pour
pour ça ils n'ont pas de structure
partie ils n'ont pas l'aura qu'on peut
contester d'un eric zemmour est
évidemment vous demain si vous voulez
vous pouvez vous présenter à la
candidature tenter par ce
regard des gens locaux qui nous dit
justement propos de deux parties un tout
citoyen quel qu'il soit doit pouvoir se
présenter le mur que dresse ses 500
signatures bij appartenir à un parti qui
par ce fait oublier d'intégrer une
obédience politique vous venez nous dire
en substance un petit peu ça c'est pas
la vieille politique beaucoup finalement
le français rejette aujourd'hui alexis
poulain cette espèce d'obédience un
parti politique qui empêche finalement
des candidatures un peu plus original
entre guillemets ou décidant de se
présenter je dirais pas que c'est la
vieille politique je dirais que c'est
une crise qui n'est pas nouvelle en fait
d'aider des parties de la représentation
politique
on a deux crises en fait la crise des
partis en tant que tel on voit à gauche
c'est flagrant c'est à dire que même
avec le parti socialiste anne hidalgo ne
décolle pas dans les sondages ça ne
fonctionne pas on est en train de faire
là la gauche est en train de savoir qui
va y aller qui n'y va pas enfin bref ça
ne fonctionne pas et puis il ya un
problème de représentativité aujourd'hui
on a une assemblée nationale qui n'est
pas représentatif du peuple français et
ça c'est le problème depuis longtemps
dire qu'on a toujours ce débat sur la
proportionnelle à savoir pourquoi les
élus finalement sont si peu
représentatif du peuple ben voilà pour
cette raison là et c'est vrai que les
français du coup soit s'abstiennent soit
vote blanc soit refuse carrément le jeu
politique ou bien vont chercher des
candidats hors système même si eric
zemmour était un ancien journaliste
qu'il connaît très bien le système qu'il
arrive à rejouer il ya ce problème là
cette défiance avec en plus le monde des
affaires le nombre d'élus qui ont été
pris la main dans le sac qui ont été
condamnés ça aussi ça discrédite
complètement la fonction politique donc
il ya deux choses à la fois la morale en
politique et la morale elle est
important tu parles pas de faim je parle
de morale politique pour le coup et puis
la représentativité et ça c'est pas
l'élection présidentielle qui va changer
quoi que ce soit on est au théâtre de
guignol on a tous les cinq ans un
produit marketing alors macron c'était
voilà le nouveau le jeune la start up
nation eric zemmour c'est la france
d'avant la france qui allait bien un peu
de nostalgie on saupoudre un peu de
d'autorité hop on revend un produit
c'est complètement infantilisant la
démocratie c'est pas voter tous les cinq
ans pour un baril de lessive c'est aller
chercher des idées c'est aller chercher
le débat politique c'est savoir ensuite
quelles vont être les moyens d'avoir une
démocratie vivante référendum
d'initiative citoyenne mandat
révocatoire pas plein de choses qui font
que les français ont confiance dans la
politique aujourd'hui c'est je pense
cette rupture de confiance qui fait
qu'on en arrive là et qu'on dit
effectivement l'échec de la cinquième
c'est cette hyper présidentialisme
assumée par emmanuel macron qui arriva à
nier même le jeu démocratique déjà
faible du parlement et pourtant les
français restent extrêmement le répète
souvent attachés à ce scrutin oui de
l'élection présidentielle même si la
dernière à démontrer que les
abstentionnistes étaient nombreux
puisque ils ont eu autant ils ont fait
autant de voix que marine le pen a une
seule deuxième tour donc c'est quand
même très important mais jusque là en
effet ça toujours été
l'élection préféré des français pourquoi
parce que la présidentielle c'est la
rencontre d'un candidat ou d'une
candidate avec les citoyens et les
électeurs et donc ça c'est évidemment
très important mais j'ajouterai à ce que
disait alexis un autre facteur peut-être
de
ceux comment dirais-je ce malaise crise
de la démocratie c'est que depuis
à les
30 40 ans vous avez eu des candidats qui
ont été élus à répétition pour monter
même jusqu'à françois mitterrand mais
que ce soit nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande emmanuel macron ils sont
arrivés avec des programmes ronflants et
une fois élu
malheureusement ils n'ont pas eu le
courage de leur parole et résultats
nicolas sarkozy a été battue quand il
s'est représenté françois hollande n'a
même pas pu lui se représenter et quant
à emmanuel macron qui a eu un
quinquennat particulièrement secoué
aussi de son fait les facteurs
extérieurs kovy de gilet jaune sont
aussi alors le qu'ovide 7-6 7/1
extérieur les faits mais les gilet jaune
il a très mal géré cette crise est au
fond
toutes les réformes qu'il avait engagé
il n'a pas pu découvrir pourtant et
pourtant
tant les perches il reste largement en
tête tout même dans les sondages
mais je sais
mais bien entamée alors les sondages
j'ai fait un sondage sur le réseau
twitter pour rigoler au deuxième tour si
elle ne le croit et efface un tabouret
pour qui voteriez-vous et les français
trente mille ont répondu à 88 %
d'intentions de vote pour le tabouret
donc les sondages on peut aller très
loin alors évidemment ce n'est pas un
sondage avec les méthodes de sondage etc
mais il ya quelque chose de terrible
dans cette candidature belge eux
l'expliquent tout simplement qu'il
m'appelle macron ne défend pas son bilan
il fait des promesses il fait des
chèques avec notre argent depuis
septembre depuis sa visite à marseille
il est en campagne sans l'être et tout
ce qu'il fait c'est plutôt que de
défendre son bilan qui est indéfendable
aucune réforme n'a été fait il n'a pas
respecté son programme il a été dans une
dérive autocratique terrible il a été le
président de la violence du mépris il
insulte les français maintenant en
voulant les emmerdants s'ils ne sont pas
vaccinés et donc qu'est-ce qu'il fait
bien quinze milliards pour les plats
police 30 milliards pour l'éducation 40
milliards par ci les entreprises on va
c'est notre argent on est endetté déjà
avec le co vide d'une façon inédite on
voit que les taux directeurs sont en
train de remonter 1% de plus de tous ces
30 milliards de plus à rembourser pour
la dette d'état c'est là où valérie
pécresse d'ailleurs peut faire la
différence en attaquant emmanuel macron
sur la dette parce que ce bilan d'
emmanuel macron il est indéfendable
économiquement socialement politiquement
ce président ne peut pas être élu donc
qu'est-ce qu'il fait beau il c'est une
course en avant avec des promesses et
les sondages évidemment l'aide en dix
ans mais il est formidable qui vous
voulez mettre à la place ben moi j'ai la
réponse un tabouret pas de campagne
peut-être pour les autant oui rapidement
arrivés sont bas je le fais pas non plus
une élection
où lionel jospin aujourd'hui ce que ça
va donner ils sont faits étalés au
premier tour elle pense en tout cas dans
trois mois
en tout cas tous les deux denis
demonpion alexis poulin et avant de
refermer cette émission petit détour
dans le tarn et garonne avec 7 contre un
projet d'un parc photovoltaïque dans le
petit village de bessens de nouvelles
installations sur près de 40 hectares
alors que les locaux sature un sujet
signé avec grand champ et mes nièces qui
fit
des panneaux photovoltaïques par
centaines qu'ils s'étendent sur des
dizaines d'hectares à bessens ces
installations qui fournissent du courant
agace particulièrement un opérateur
dénommé valorem souhaite installer de
nouvelles centrales solaires dans la
ville au plus grand désarroi des
habitants et surtout de la mairie
nous disposons déjà de près de 40
hectares de champs photovoltaïques pour
vous donner un exemple c'est 40 ha ça
représente à peu près la consommation de
15000 habitants bessens en à 1500 donc
c'est dix fois plus la population
béninoise donc un projet supplémentaire
aujourd'hui c'est quand même beaucoup
quand on se promène et qu'on a
l'habitude de voir des bois et qu'on se
retrouve avec des champs photovoltaïques
c'est pas du tout le même le même charme
et vous savez les habitants de bessens
sont venus s'installer à la campagne
donc c'est pas pour avoir vu sur des
champs photovoltaïques toutes les
impositions partent ailleurs et la
commune de bessens ne récupère pas un
kopeck
après avoir tenté d'interpeller à
plusieurs reprises le préfet du tarn et
garonne le maire de bessens prévoirait
d'envoyer leur nez garonne le maire de
bessens prévoirait d'envoyer une lettre
au premier ministre d'après les
informations de france bleu
les habitants de bessens affichent
également leur ras-le-bol 117 installé
dans cette maison de campagne pour
trouver un environnement verdoyant elle
voit d'année en année de nouveaux
panneaux photovoltaïques s'implanter
autour de sa propriété la nuisance qu'on
a principalement aussi c'est par rapport
à notre cadre de vie qu'on a choisi on
est venu habiter à la campagne pour être
entouré de nature on a fait ce choix et
et maintenant c'est dénaturer et par
rapport également à notre un autre
patrimoine immobilier qui du coup par
conséquent ce sens retrouve je pense
amoindrie en termes de valeur
certainement autre aspect qui provoque
la colère des locaux la faune et la
flore serait selon eux dénaturer avec
ses installations eric et président de
l'association de chasseurs de bessens
ils redoutent le projet d'une nouvelle
centrale sur ce champ un projet qui
selon lui mettrait en danger une espèce
animale je m'oppose à ce futur champ de
panneaux photovoltaïques déjà d'une part
parce que nous en avons déjà 35 ha ha et
comme vous pouvez le constater il va
encore nous installer ces panneaux sur
une zone verte et une future de zones de
réservoir biologique où ils se trouvent
des orchidées qui sont très rares et
notamment l'animal qui est très protégé
à ginette des bois pour l'heure le bras
de fer continue entre la commune et le
promoteur énergétique contacté par notre
chaîne valorem n'a pas souhaité répondre
en attendant plusieurs centaines de
signatures ont été recueillies dans la
pétition s'opposant au projet d'une
nouvelle centrale mais c'est la
préfecture qui aura le dernier mot dans
ce dossier après une étude complète du
projet en question en france le solaire
photovoltaïque occupe une place de plus
en plus importante d'après les
prévisions du réseau de transport
d'électricité 4 millions de logements
dans l'hexagone pourraient être équipés
en installation photovoltaïque d'ici
2030 et c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi rendez vous
demain dès 20h10 iea n'oubliez pas de
réagir de commenter posez vos questions
sur le télégramme d'air france en
attendant l'actualité continue toute la
soirée en direct excellente
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple c'était
une volonté collective vous le savez
pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative on sort du côté il est
clair que tout le monde attend saft
est ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on